[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh là là mais qu'est-ce qui fait depuis
tout à l'heure il y a un char à voile
qui fait n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors un truc que j'adore en Corée du
Sud et qui fait que pour moi la Corée du
Sud est un bien meilleur pays que la
France c'est que dans les arrêts de bus
ici comme vous pouvez le voir les bons
sont chauffés c'est genre or ça fait
vraiment beaucoup de bien c'est à dire
tu posté mains là c'est
souvent on me donne des conseils comme
si je savais pas les choses mais oh
je suis poney de la dernière pluie
tu connais
je vous donne mes astuces à moi
maintenant je vais me dire
je donne un petit tuyau ou quoi
non non c'est la guerre faut arrêter la
sororité tout ça c'est bon c'est bon là
j'ai des talons je vais essayer de d'en
assommer quelques-unes c'est la moindre
des choses